[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
[Music]
happy 4th of july
independence day
celebrating
our independence even though
this year we have less freedom than we
had last year let's make sure
that this year we we do not make sure we
have less freedom next year gabe welcome
to this special edition of the tony
michaels podcast on the fourth of july i
like your hand it's very well thank you
very patriotic
a real patriot not a patriot not a
patriot not a patriot
on this on this great
day but it is a dark day as well um
because we do know that
citizens in our country now have less
freedom than they did last fourth of
july so it's tough to celebrate freedom
in that way right
we should still we should still
celebrate our democracy on this day
because um that is something that us as
pro-democracy people can still hang on
to if we want to is our democracy
because we are the democracy right never
forget that
on this independence day so so celebrate
the freedoms that you still may have and
the liberties that you still may have
and that the freedoms and liberties to
come as we the liberal world order
take over our democracy
and lay down the hammer of democracy on
these fascists uh gabe this is a special
episode today because it is july 4th a
couple weeks ago
i was at the dentist and you interviewed
you interviewed uh a special doctor here
so i want i want you to introduce us
to this clip and to the interview that
you have here because it's about 50
minutes long i believe um and you guys
go into some detail about covid
and really being cautious uh about covid
and saying that it's over and some other
things so tell us a little bit about
this interview who it is with and tell
us the background on it and then we'll
get to the interview here yeah so i had
the pleasure of interviewing dr eric
feiglding who's uh he's an
epidemiologist and he's a um
he's the person that some might know on
twitter but he's one of the first people
to kind of sound the alarm when it came
to cover 19. so very grateful to kind of
you know have his time and a moment to
just ask him questions we discuss covet
obviously talk about the past two years
in the roller coaster we've been on you
know we discussed hitting a million
deaths as well as other red states and
how they approached it versus blue
states and
and just kind of the unfortunate
political mess that we're in because of
covid and you know certain leaders aka
trump not taking it seriously as well as
the rest of the republican party and now
we're seeing those effects you know that
long-term effect of covet different
variants and and kind of the situation
that we're in right now
and how we as a country whether it's
person to person or within our community
can do a better job of dealing with it
because it's it unfortunately is one of
those things that we now have to kind of
live with uh but it's how can we make
that better for everyone around us
including ourselves so that it doesn't
you know overtake our lives again
so without further ado let's go to the
interview and welcome back to the show
today we're joined by epidemiologist
health economist and founder of the
world health network eric feigl ding
thanks for having me so now for uh those
of our viewers who don't know you uh you
were one of the first people to kind of
sound the alarm about cover 19. can you
talk a little bit about that yeah well
this is very early uh 2020 in january
2020. um
a lot of people were kind of very
hesitant to kind of shout at the rooftop
people were very concerned but many of
them didn't want to say it because they
didn't want to scare the public or be
labeled a fear-monger alarmist but i
think in certain ways the public has a
right to know and
i felt like i have less to lose and i'm
an epidemiologist
um
and it's
kind of like a public duty to warn right
there's a duty to warn when you're sure
about some impending
um
calamity that is coming that's going to
affect not just the country but the
whole world
and obviously since then millions of
people have died but but early on people
were scared of
saying what they feared the most
because in many ways it was the sum of
all fears of many many scientists but
they dare not say something because it's
been over 100 years so
i
you know i went hard and strong early on
saying this is going to be a
thermonuclear level bad
pandemic the world has not seen in 100
years and
here we are so
but i think i think continued advocacy
uh despite many people's
um being tired or fatigued
is really critical
especially since you know people have
attention
deficits on social media and media in
general but obviously a pandemic in the
virus does not care about your
adhd or if you're suddenly distracted by
something else the virus will still
virus and this is why
continued advocacy is really important
you actually touched on this so you know
we've seen millions of deaths you know
in in the world but here at home
we uh we just you know officially hit a
million deaths and i know there's you
know confirmed deaths versus excess
deaths um
can you explain a little bit of the
difference and why it matters yeah we
officially hit one million confirmed but
that's just those who are test confirmed
and there's excess obviously in january
in early spring 2020 where we missed a
lot of deaths because we never got
during this surge in new york and
in new england we had so many deaths
that we didn't even have time to test
them and confirm they were coveted
and access also captures
excesses is total deaths
above and beyond the historical average
rate
and what that means is you know the the
at the average for example um 2015 2019
you know some people go even further but
if you average them and their
seasonality you know it's always higher
in the winter so accounts for
seasonality accounts for historical
averages in some years a little blip
here and there but above
beyond this historical average what is
the excess number of deaths
and
and to excess deaths we hit over a
million excess back in february
2022
and excess also captures the indirect
effects the secondary spillover effects
for example
as many people remember icus and
hospitals were full what if you needed
an ic icu or hospital for your surgery
for your cancer for your heart attacks
for car accidents
guess what if the hospital beds are full
then you don't get seen right away
you're not prioritized
if ers are full if the ambulance's
weights are like two hours and you have
a heart attack or stroke you may not get
your care and you might die at home or
wherever you had your heart attack
stroke or car accident and this is the
this indirect spillover effect where
a host of other healthcare dilemmas are
completely backlogged and people die
when quality care drops and so in many
ways we also see this happening that you
know when during surges we actually have
higher deaths of other things too
so excess that they are still pandemic
deaths if the pandemic did not
completely swamp the ers and icus and
and the ambulance services
a lot more people would still be alive
even if they did not directly die of
cobit there was still a covet pandemic
death and that's what excess death
captures and that's why it's so many you
know there's a lot of people who play
this oh he died
with kovid not from kobe right you've
heard of that well yes there are some
who have incidental covet um but you
know also that
hospitals there was a lot of hus people
who got infected in hospital they came
in the hospital covered negative
and then within like a few days or a
week they actually got coded and then
they also died and because covet also
exacerbates any other risk factors you
have and so uh and by the way most
studies show it's about you know 60 to
70 percent two thirds
three fourths
who actually
died actually you know from cove
if they tested positive for covet and so
and we also we also have something
called you know hospital records uh and
death certificates death certificates
still say it's from covid right i think
those who men try to minimize you know
say oh remember early days oh it's just
the flu they were dead wrong oh you
don't need a mask they were dead wrong
oh uh don't worry kids are immune um
they're dead wrong because you know oh
well over a thousand kids have died on
covet and also it's not just the kids
deaths first of all kids are not
supposed to die period you know
you can say oh kid pediatric deaths oh
19 gunshot deaths it's still low in the
grand scheme of the country blah blah
blah
no these are 19 year uh
kids at a school did not deserve to die
they did not deserve to die whether from
a gunshot
or from covet right they do not deserve
to die and i also remind people it's not
just to direct the deaths of of kids or
hot spots and die but also
losing a parent's caretaker and um the
official term is being orphaned being
warfare is not just losing both your
parents and all relatives uh you know
being orphaned um is you know is also
losing caretaker
including a parent
and you know
i think like tens of thousands i forget
the latest numbers uh since they're a
couple months old now tens of thousands
of children worth it and you want to
talk about mental health of children who
lost their parents
that is something that you can never
ever fix or replace
um
and so i think you know there's many
people who dismiss risk in kids and by
the way more kids have died uh over time
with each of the variant waves than they
did before like more kids have died in
2022
um than all the previous two years of
the pandemic combined and
people just try to ignore them right now
just as we speak
uh pediatric hospitalizations for covid
are at a three and a half month high
and they've doubled since some
since early april
um you can't you can't do if ands or
buts about this this is still a rising
tragedy and
kids should not be hospitalized period
so
i think those who dismiss the risks
downplayed minimized they honestly have
blood on their hands i think during the
pandemic there was very much this
dunning-kruger effect where everyone was
like within two weeks to a month knew
everything that they had to know about
covet right despite all the years of
schooling and experience in times that
you've actually been on the front line
studying viruses they said i'm the real
epidemiologist right i'm the person who
knows that
it's
a hoax or it's made in a lab or it's no
worse than the flu right you know but
i'm curious like as an epidemiologist as
an actual epidemiologist as someone who
who knew this was going to be a serious
thing
you know how did we get to the state
that we're in right now this is a very
good question obviously this is a very
long pandemic and
this info misinfo had played a very
large part of it
but also political
inaction
political expediency and
just sometimes downright ostrich
head in the sand approach to coven
hoping that it would just go away i
think obviously we know that this info
and miss info is very powerful um
a lot of these messages very viral
they can go around the world three times
before the truth has the chance to get
its boots on and debunking is almost
never as effective as the original viral
miss info
and you know
hydroxychloroquine ivermectin so much of
this has wasted a lot of time they're
not proven treatments the proven
treatments have been drowned out by a
lot of this information
and you know the natural immunity oh i
have
god gave me immune system for a reason
yeah
well i remind people first of all if
they did not survive and a lot of people
didn't survive their first wave
dead men tell no tales that they're not
here to say well no it's not enough
only those who were barely surviving and
recovered
are able to even barely say that
so i think in many ways
people just heard from their social
networks that oh it's just like the flu
and you know let's be honest a lot of
the january february march early
articles the mainstream news said oh
it's just the flu you don't need to wear
a mask
that was incredibly dangerous so
obviously disinfo was very dangerous it
got people killed um
but also just natural social network
effects of bad information
um
and complacency and even the mainstream
media early on you know played a role in
you know basically
allaying people's fears and oh don't
worry about this but clearly they were
all wrong
clearly this is really bad we have had
over a million
confirmed deaths recently and over a
million excess deaths in the u.s since
february
um and worldwide anywhere from 15
million to over 20 million 15 million
being close to the who estimate uh and
20 million being the economist estimate
of total deaths worldwide covet
this is this is not a lightweight
pandemic
this is absolutely serious and people
have completely ignored that with a wide
variety of of excuses from from like oh
he died uh you know
with covet instead of front cover
whenever we know that for the medical
records most people died
from actually covid or the indirect
effects of covid
it's it's basically
the short-term complacency is very easy
it's very seductive it's very alluring
to believe that you know oh kids are
immune
and oh you know 19 kids dying not a big
deal whether it's gun violence or cove
kids are not supposed to die and all
together this is just
a huge huge reflection of our society
how fractured it is how the information
is siloed among those who want to
believe whatever they want to believe in
their little network and based on
whatever their political leaders or
pundits promote
um and of course the vaccine miss info
is is obviously the worst of all that
the red states that had the least
vaccination rates least boosted rates
have
way way more
coveted hospitalizations
and deaths than the counties and states
that have the most vaccinations
and
i think there's blood on the hands of a
lot of those who spread that vaccine and
sinful there's blood on hands for a lot
of those who spread the
covet denialism coven minimization oh
covet is over messaged
kids are practically immune they have
blood on their hands
um and
so many things have gone wrong and even
the cdc have
has not been the best
in you know recognizing breakthrough
infections how even though breakthroughs
rarely lead to death breakthroughs can
still trigger
outbreaks and complete new epidemic
clusters
um
but of course unless it happened in the
u.s like for example the providence town
fourth of july uh cape cod outbreak last
last fourth of july unless that you know
it happened on u.s soil with u.s data oh
all the lessons of the delta variant um
you know basically
uh causing three to four million deaths
in india in the spring of last year oh
that doesn't matter that's not real it's
because it's not here those far away
that's india right it could never happen
here
and of course delta baron happened here
and it caused hundreds of thousands of
deaths in the summer and early fall
um you know i think complacency kills
right and and
this pandemic has teaches us that we
should always be precautious
taking the precautionary
approach saves lives and actually saves
the economy if you act early you can
actually save your economy a way better
than when all hell breaks loose
and
people um you know entire
industries are disrupted like airlines
even delta airline who fought so hard to
reduce isolation and fought against mass
you know they had to emit over memorial
day weekend
um yeah we had a lot of cancellations
due to
a higher than expected covet absences
well no crap we've been warning about
that the same thing happened with
british airways and easyjet at heathrow
airport just a month ago in april no
crap the same thing would happen in
america no crap that if you minimize
ignore covet your own
workers
and you know own um operations will be
disrupted because you know
people have such a short-term mindset
they want
they want things to be back to normal
they don't see what's around the corner
they don't see the domino effect of
[ __ ] hitting the fan and all hell
breaking loose later on obviously these
companies you know they're saying well
we need people we need butts in the
seats and we need to make money and the
only way to do that is to ensure that we
have a very short turnaround time from
either our passengers or our workers
included however that short-sightedness
that that allure of
uh of making money you know profit over
people
really drives
a further spread an outbreak where they
say okay well now we have too many
people out that can't run the airline we
can't we don't have pilots we don't have
flight attendants
you know whoever yeah whoever but they
already have your ticket money for the
most part exactly right they're like
well you know it's not our fault we
cancelled even though it is their fault
that they can use right and they never
compete airlines never compensate fully
right yeah they will they will fight
they will you know they will scream they
will claw their way to make sure that
they don't you know that you don't get
your money back despite the fact that
they made a very reckless decision
against human life
to further their own company profits
right and we've seen it of course
eventually they'll ask for bailout money
like they did last right and i was just
gonna say they they clearly in the past
asked for bailout money and then you
know despite being told don't use this
bailout money for you know you know
stock buybacks they say okay we won't
and then of course they do and then when
the airline needs money to help they say
what happened and then they say well we
use the money for the buyback you know
so it's clearly that these companies
obviously their self-interest is is
their own right they don't care about
others as long as there's money and um
you also touched on how
you know this disinformation is such
it is a very much a viral
kind of spread as much as the actual
virus itself right you've got you know
as of yesterday
uh we've got according to an audit you
know florida had uncounted covet cases
and deaths and failed to actually get
the test results now we knew
you know anyone with an actual kind of
brain inability to kind of look at what
was going on we knew that ron desantis
or as many renamed him as to death
scientists you know looked at the stuff
and said we will
overcome covid and we
we're going to open things back up and
you don't have to wear masks and you
know science is
it's you know it's it's fantasy it's not
real but do you think that we'll see
more of these audits come out and reveal
themselves to say oh the actual
leaders of this of the state uh kind of
dropped the ball
to as a way to own the libs or defy you
know logic well i think first of all the
the fact that we had an audit in uh
florida was a miracle a small miracle
right now already um
and there are certain things that
artists can't even pick up like for
example reporting biases and reporting
tricks for example if you're a new
yorker go to spring break in florida
catch covid
go to hospital
go to a hospital in
florida not not just you
went back to new york after spring break
um but even if you went to a hospital in
uh florida but your new york resident
who was visiting for spring break your
code wouldn't count and
as a case or a hospitalization or death
because you're not florida resident
right and then there's other tricks for
example the delayed reporting that you
always report the actual
date of death but what happens is
there's always like a two to four to six
week lag
and so if you only look at the date of
death it always looks like the cases are
dropping because in the most recent
weeks all our cases our cases and deaths
are very very low our deaths are very
low in the last week because of natural
reporting of delay by actual data that
most states don't do that and again it's
another way of to hide it
there's a lot of things in which
you know
you can
you can also point out but
in south dakota where i i had a
childhood um
partial par part of my upbringing i
lived in south dakota for a few years
um south dakota you know people said oh
south dakota never look it's we're not
new york city population dense we're
south dakota we have one of the lowest
population densities in the whole whole
country it's not going to affect us
but um
look look what happened south dakota has
one of the highest per capita deaths
right and this is inherently a product
of complacency and it spreads way
faster in
complacent
uh dismissive social networks more than
anything this is a social
disease phenomenon because of the nature
of airborne transmission
and um and how you cluster
and also i would tell people
you know herd immunity first of all that
assumes that your immunity is
near lifelong or at least five ten years
which it clearly is not so you should
not rely on her immunity and second of
all um those who assumes that there's
equal admixtures at uh say at a prom uh
which you know uh
say
someone on the other side of the room
has it but there's a crowded
dance floor and then um of people who
are mostly vaccinated and and the chance
of the virus hop skipping through them
to you is low in muslim vaccinating but
the reality is vaccinated people hang
out with vaccinated and unvaccinated
people oftentimes hang out with
unvaccinated or low vaccinated
populations so a super spreads in one
population and spreads slower in another
population but in the end
you know if you had cut the population
of new york and in half or in divided by
three you would still be more dense than
south dakota
and uh it would still spread
regardless of population density
there's there's a whole range of
phenomenon that you know there's
complete denialism and minimization and
unscientific just complete uh propaganda
because it's inconvenient
the inconvenient truth right right
uh it's so easy
it's also a
reality in corporate america it's so
easy to focus on the quarterly profits
and the long-term profits long-term
health it's so easy to focus on the
immediate political
polls and political next election that's
coming up in a few months
than uh than the actual
um long-term health of a country or
economy
um you know what is uh what is popular
is not always right and what is right is
not always popular
and i think we've learned a deep lesson
in our country that
governing our country with his political
fractionalization of red state's blue
states
and how polarized vaccines are
and mass are
is uh is a horrible horrible example of
how our country is very poorly equipped
to deal with a pendant 100 and i feel
like the pandemic itself has rewired a
lot of people's brains unfortunately you
know and it's caused people which is
i this is kind of crazy to say it has
caused people to question science the
political side of this has unfortunately
seeped its way into
this uh this virus which again doesn't
care if you're left right middle
you know brown purple or yellow do you
think
with all of this that is happening we
talked about disinformation we talked
about these you know red states that
have
you know not done their job we've talked
about this complacency to
wait it out and and not actually take
proactive measures do you think we'll
get back to a state of normalcy or do
you think we're
you know unfortunately ultimately
screwed we're not screwed screwed
but we're stuck in here in a rut until
something new happens
it's
because you know we have newer drugs yes
they're good pax logo is good um but not
everyone can afford or access paxo by
the way us government is in debt to
pfizer um it needs a 10 billion dollars
and the first few billions is actually
to repay pfizer for all the tax low but
it's loaned on the government so it's
not a long term kind of thing and you
know america you know the health care
access
totally depends on who your doctor is or
if or if you can afford it to see the
doctor in the first place
these are long-standing
crisis in american health care that's
not been solved
so that's that um
and and uh you know i also tell people
you know we we obviously need like
long-term better
vaccines and our vaccines right now are
good but they're like hospitalization
and death prevention vaccines for the
majority people but they're not
infection prevention vaccines anymore
given the variance in the old days they
were but with the variance
the variants are very evasive against
just basic infection against vaccines we
need either better vaccines
that are like sterilizing immunity um
that some people say some of the nasal
vaccines could do that
they're still far away's off yeah the
drugs the drugs again also are their
scarcity and there's access
affordability issues
um
again they're also hospitalization and
death prevention drugs they're not
infection prevention drugs and
and of course we're not boosted enough
but boosters reduce your infection you
know 70 in the first few weeks but after
10 weeks it's less than 50 percent so i
always tell people like this look think
of your your body as a vehicle as a
conduit a like a four-lane bridge
highway bridge is your bridge going to
collapse the chances are not if you're
boosted your vaccinated boosted
especially if you're boosted your chance
of your bridge is not going to collapse
you're not going to die most likely
but the problem is that although you
close two lanes of the four lane bridge
you're still sending traffic across your
body
uh if you're not careful across the
remaining two lanes and and here's what
that means like in the old days um
you're at least precautious think 2020
before the vaccines many people were
very cautious
even some of the naysayers they were
still pretty cautious but
what happened was now that you have
amazing wonder drugs monopoly antibodies
which are easily evaded you know they're
not long-term solutions
uh we have great drugs uh we have
testing which by the way we we rarely
report anymore because home testing is
rarely reported right we have great
vaccines the problem is now people feel
invulnerable
if they feel invulnerable what happens
is for example when we first had um
airbags
people started driving faster when we
installed airbags
um and same with seat belts there was
this initial thing and with our hiv drug
cocktails when the wonder cocktails that
would prevent you from dying showed up
for hiv
people became more promiscuous because
they felt invulnerable
and the chance the issue is that the
s
with covid people now start going to
nightclubs crowded bars and restaurants
and crowded uh other parties uh and
carelessly instead of you know doing on
the patio deck outdoors and a cookout
they do it inside
and that actually increases your dose
increase your volume uh of virus that
you're exposed to and expel um
effectively you're putting more traffic
across this bridge even though it's
two-lane high of the four-lane highway
closed just now we're putting more
traffic more exposure across the bridge
and yes the chances are you're not gonna
the bridge is not gonna collapse but
guess what most of america is not
boosted uh uk data says that against ba2
if you're two shot vaccinated you have a
59
efficacy
59 is good
but it's not as good as the 95 percent
used to be right right and and if you're
boosted you have compared to an
unvaccinate you have 22x lower risk of
death
but how much of america is boosted uh
you know i was i think like less than
half
uh only 30 percent of of kids 5 to 11
are
even have two shots and they're now
eligible for boosters so the boosters in
the single digits um but even two shots
vaccines of kids five to eleven it's not
very high so altogether if you think of
what now omicron being
milder because of
drugs and vaccines it's actually uh
could actually
have a domino effect if people think
you're they're vulnerable and put out
way more transmission
right and so in certain ways we're still
in this kind of like this
honeymoon period after the winter you
know omicron wave
but you know within six months the
waning really kicks in
right so you know about a third of
america probably got infected according
to you know new york
about a third of america got infected in
in the january uh december january
omicron way but um your omnicron aid
protection against variant variants not
so good
um and it wanes after six months so i
think i think you know we're already in
oversearch uh pediatric hospitalizations
are at a three-month high it's double
what they was in april
and hospitalizations in america are also
increasing uh again adult both adults
and kids
you know we
our complacency
um
is is really going to pay a heavy price
so i think in certain ways what can we
do i say well hepa filters indoor
ventilation because in certain ways it's
agnostic of vaccines or mass obviously
i'm pro vaccine pro masking
but i recognize a lot of america just
doesn't want to do it so if you don't
want to do it then at least install hepa
filters everywhere upper room uv
um
open the windows ventilate the air like
those are the basic like politically
agnostic i hope opening the window is
politically neutral right but god knows
someone could make it political um but
hippo filters upper room uv disinfect
the air but we're not doing that we
don't have those guidelines installed
and of course you know mask mandates are
just
after the airline debacle you know right
now it's really hard to get people
back on the wagon to wear masks you know
even though she's just begging people oh
we should wear masks again you know what
cat's out of bag people don't want to
wear masks anymore
the information whiplash
is too much for every people and yes i
think we're stuck for quite a while you
know you make a good point there is you
know this information overload like i
think you know the beginning like you
mentioned there were people even
skeptics that were taking it seriously
to an extent
and you know the more that comes out
there's always someone saying well this
outdates this and this outdates that and
then you're trying to figure out what
actually is the actual source of truth
and there's a bunch of doubt that's
sowed into agencies like the cdc and
other places where you're like well if
they can't get it right then how do we
know it's a real thing you know and and
of course you know i was just uh you
even mentioned um airlines i was on a
flight not too long ago
when masks were still required
and uh
the the flight attendant you know it was
clear where she
kind of sat on the political spectrum
because the mask was
a mesh mask so it was just for show but
not obviously for function uh and my
girlfriend and i kind of had a giggle
and we're like oh god we are so screwed
um
because these people
are are technically following the
guidelines but doing so so that it you
know it appeases people but doesn't
actually
help in preventing further spread
um and you also mentioned something
about testing you know i think we we are
very fortunate that we are you know
we've had two rounds of these free tests
that have gone out through around
three rounds okay i don't get any more
tests now as of last week or so so we've
had multiple rounds now we've been very
fortunate enough that our our government
has said you know uh
have these at home whenever you feel
maybe symptoms get tested now the
downside though
is like you mentioned
it's very much up to you um there's no
way for this to go there's no
centralized database there's no place
where people can report it i can't you
know take a photo or like another
country as you can
you know many of our rapids has actually
have a qr code on the rapid cartridge
because they're made it for worldwide
use and in europe you have like a qr
code like self-test reporting system but
in america
nope we don't really have any of that
it's really sad and
some some states and counties have had
them for a while but no one used them
and so because there was no public
momentum or like political and policy
messaging around them and i think you
know the other thing too is like every
state you know states rights or whatever
you want to call it every state has
their own control of their own data
right they're not
funneling that into a place where uh
[Music]
where everyone can access it right you
know they're they're they're restrictive
if they don't want to show the numbers
like florida and other places they don't
really have to show the numbers or they
can finesse them or you know they can
they can skew them to make it seem like
it's much
uh brighter
in in their their part of the country um
than than it might be actually happening
but
um
so we've got these self-tests and one
thing i'm curious that maybe you can
shed some light on is like i know that
there are other ways to kind of get
population
um
uh numbers right without having to rely
on
self-tests uh i think one of them is
wastewater wastewater that's right um
can you talk just briefly about that
yeah wastewater is um is something which
i say you know poop doesn't lie because
you could test everyone poops
um and the water sewage system unless
you're in a rural area that has a lot of
septic tanks right except to tanks are
not connected to a centralized sewer but
short of set areas that rely heavily on
septic tanks the sewage is like the
common denominator
of
of a lot of exposure and you can test
them now granted there are some you know
rats and stuff like that that um
that is not part of
human exposure but there it's the best
unbiased barometer
and wastewater search rises and they
rise faster than case report surge
rises and
they're really unbiased because in
certain ways
if if self-testing is biased
political reporting and policy reporting
is biased
then wastewater is is a really good
metric um
so these kind of surveillance things are
are really important
um
i can't stress enough that uh not every
county in america invests in wastewater
uh surveillance only some counties in
some states have them
and again we're just kind of like poking
in the dark with like a radar in like
only less than a quarter of all counties
that we have such data but the data that
we do have is it paints a very dark
picture of cases rising again across the
entire us and sometimes you can also
tell us about variants because in many
ways
you know delta by the way is almost
extinct
it's still there it's sometimes rising
some places but it's always almost
always displaced by the new variance
and the new variance is
always the threat to existing immunity
whether it's natural
past infection immunity or or
uh or vaccine which by the way is
natural too
because you teach your body how to deal
with you make your vaccine teaches you
how to make your own antibodies so it's
still natural as opposed to monocle
antibodies which is like you give a man
a fish and teach him how to fight a
virus a vaccine you teach your body how
to how to fight the virus
but the variants are clearly a problem
because you're only teaching it but
based on the original
vaccine or the original virus that you
had encountered with and
and uh
you know no one has gotten the message
out among a lot of the right wing crowd
that your immunity wanes
and
a new variant means a new way to dodge
your body's defense systems right um
it's you know it's if you ever watch
star trek you know you can get a phaser
off on a board the first two times but
quickly the borg adapts and you're not
gonna get the phaser off against them
they're gonna invade
and i think no one talks about that
anymore like i i i could scream on
twitter all day about this
and you know
i you know obviously there's a lot of
retweets and and whatnot but it's mostly
still among
the echo chamber of those who want to
listen those who don't want to listen
don't want to hear they don't see it
even if they would actually find it kind
of curious because they're
the leaders of their eco champ echo
chamber are just not uh not talking
about it because it's
an inconvenient truth
i think
climate change scientists at the
beginning of the pandemic say so now you
epidemiologists know how we feel though
and
whether that or monkey pox
you know there's a lot of dismissal
monkey box is not that big of a deal
except cdc raised a level two alert uh
from level one
um say you should wear masks but no one
hears about any of that stuff right even
the news article that even mentions a
level two they don't mention that oh cdc
also said you should wear a mask
like the mainstream media is not even
reporting it right
there they've gone on obviously the the
gun tragedy is horrible
and uh and no kids should die of that
but of guns just like no kids should die
of covid or these other you know these
acute
uh unexplained hepatitis that's also
going around um
we don't talk about anymore and it's
just like out of sight out of mind
a lot of our media sphere
feels like you know talking about is
unpopular but again what is popular is
not always right what is right is not
always popular and we're in such a
reactionary country that we only react
when [ __ ] hits the fan
um you know when when hospitals are
overloaded again that's when we act
but i tell people that's not public
health
do we say oh today hospital beds are not
full you don't need to wear a helmet to
a bicycling or go riding down on the
freeway on a motorcycle you don't need a
helmet hot world beds are not full you
don't need a helmet you don't need um
you don't need a seat belt today
hospital beds are not full you know what
drink and driving you know let's double
the legal threshold because hospital
beds are not full you know it's okay
you know speed limit raises 120.
it's all right hospital beds are not
full drunk driving
totally okay double the legal limit like
who who says that no one says that that
is not public health it's it's centers
for disease control and prevention
public health is about preventing
disease as opposed to medicine which is
oftentimes you know crisis management
after you have a disease after you've
suffered the illness and an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure but
no one wants to invest in the ounce of
prevention when it could have been
prevented in the first place
and and obviously a there's financial
incentives uh that they're misaligned
and also that public health when it's
successful it's invisible like if say 10
people were getting killed at this
pedestrian intersection of this busy
street
uh and then next year you put a you know
a crosswalk sign a tunnel a sky bridge
over it and nobody dies
there it never makes the news no one's
grateful those 10 people who would have
died there are not grateful
for the action of installing the sky
bridge that saved their life and
therefore nothing happened to them that
day
that's the nature of public health when
it's successful it's silent when it's
silent you don't get money because it
doesn't it's like
you know how that is squeaky wheel gets
the oil and budgets and government and
policy but there's nothing to squeak
because you've successfully prevented it
then you never get funding or at the
public attention they only get public
attention when
hospital beds are full and then it's
like oh someone should have done
something about this before it got this
bad
that's what public health is but it's
always underfunded it's always invisible
when it is successful and when it
it fails because
someone ignored it or underfunded it oh
it's like oh
we failed us yeah because you guys
didn't listen uh from the beginning
that's the world in which it's not just
public health it's it's gun violence you
know we only act on gun violence when
there's mass shootings but then after uh
or two weeks or so they've all
calculated oh news reporting on gun
violence and gun policies always
weighing after two weeks so we just need
to ride out this with this wave of just
say let's not political let's politicize
it oh it's too soon
right um but hey when they first learned
that oh that the uvalde shooter might be
an undocumented immigrant oh my god
let's shut down the borders right oh my
god let's do we have to do something and
then it was turned out that that was
wrong
he wasn't undocumented oh then it's like
oh oops i guess there's nothing we can
do now
it's bad things happen you know bad
people you can't stop bad people but you
know when it's politically expedient
they go right into it so of course this
politicization of a lot of these
tragedies
and
public health kind of things whether
it's gun violence or covert prevention
it is so political it is so nakedly
obviously political and um expedient
and basically
inconvenient based
um whether we want to choose to
recognize a crisis or not we sadly live
in a country where we react and we
aren't very proactive and like you said
when we are proactive then people don't
notice because they say
well things aren't a problem
but they don't realize that it's it's
working as it should because you know we
did our job to make sure that it didn't
happen right
um and whether it's gun violence or it's
you know uh
public health for covet or what have you
lead poisoning influence yeah you know
all of these things that people are like
well people don't die from these things
anymore because we took the proper steps
to prevent that from happening
you know it's just again out of sight
out of mind
if we have enough beds then we can uh we
can
easily solve the problem which is insane
to even think about this also reminds me
of exxon valdez remember the big oil
spill
back in the i think 90s or late 80s it's
been so long ago but exxon valdez um
back then oil tankers only were required
to have a single haul but after after
exxon valdez major oil spill that
destroyed wildlife then they finally put
in oh maybe we should require double
hauling these tankers carrying hundreds
of millions of gallons of oil
every year
and of course it always takes a tragedy
before we like beef up our regulations
but until then regulations are horrible
they're anti-jobs or anti
anti-anti-economy
until of course
it destroys uh people's lives it
destroys uh our wildlife destroys our
health and then of course we care this
is repeats all over again
you know
aaron brockvich's fight for clean uh
clean water
um you know the other
um
dupont chemical factories in west
virginia featured in dark waters right
again these things only when tragedy
happens do we ever do anything and this
is always the nature that i i fear
like that makes a difference between
good government
and a mismanaged government a good
government will make sure that not only
trains run on time but you know that the
trains are kept clean and are we we keep
things tidy and working
as opposed to just waiting for a tragedy
before we react and because reactionary
societies are always asking for more
trouble and it really is putting a band
in on a problem you know instead of
actually looking systemically like
what's going on
and reading the symptoms it's like well
we'll fix this by and we'll just quickly
place it here and we won't worry about
until later and then when that you know
that wound opens up again or it becomes
infected then we say okay well is there
a bigger band-aid we can put on it you
know as opposed to
what's causing the infection you know
um
and so i was going to ask you i mean i
know that you touched on it before but
like you know as
as we lead into a world that is
obviously we live in this covered world
we're we're going to see something like
this again in our future whether it's
ours or
you know the next following generations
and generations and so on you know
outside of opening windows getting uh
hepa filters you know are there anything
else that i mean and obviously outside
of the the the actual things of wearing
a mask and getting vaccines and boosters
is there anything else that we can do
for everyday lay public this is a very
tricky question for everyday lay public
you know hepa filters
advocating for more prevention measures
wearing masks getting boosters
is all they can do um and of course also
you know uh if you can't afford hepa
filters build a corsey box with these
you know these uh filters with box fan
or boxing in front and build into a cube
shape a device
and um
and you can filter it almost as good as
a hepa filter if you know how to just
build these corsey rosenthal boxes just
look it up it's a lot of people have
built them and donated them to other
schools and other workplaces and
um they're really really effective
that's you know in terms of on the on
the ground those are the lay things that
you should do and of course
uh i always tell people don't get shot
in freuda
if say some people don't want to
vaccinate or mask and uh some people
have this attitude well they're just
idiots first of all don't denigrate them
like let them be but and also focus on
the fact that you know even though they
might be of different political
affiliation from you
uh they could be our restaurant workers
um they could be our teachers
fire fighters and police officers that
you know and people in our neighborhood
and community that a we
should rely on and help each other and
could also cross-infect other people you
know
so you should still
care for your neighbors even if they
have a different political belief or
covet covet belief system from you
because i think we need to have the
empathy don't have shot in freuda or
like oh
you know darwin will take care of this
like that's that's still a very negative
and
um pernicious
attitude i don't want people to have
we're all in this together and we're not
going to get out of this together until
we at least recognize the the humanity
of our common man around us so
as much as things are politicized and
again public health is public policy
public policy is dictated by politics
um i still want people to see
each other as humans
and not just
those are those are idiots he deserve he
or she deserves to die don't do not have
that feeling
obviously long term we need more funding
for
medical research for the sterilizing
vaccines
i encourage people to join clinical
trials whenever possible
um
and by the way clinicaltrials.gov is the
ultimate registry of new trials that's
on the horizon you can see what
uh trials there are whether for cancer
or for covid that's actively recruiting
you can see
what's going on um
but i think advocating for funding for
public health
for the invisible
effectiveness of public health
it's it's incredibly important
and
and i think in many ways the electing
leaders who will fund these
scientific and public health
policies to save lives
i think that's really important and if
your area is too
too politically polarized to elect
someone who who can do that
just advocate advocate forcefully
um
be the voice in your community who will
be the you know the rational voice
for science for public health because
you know the
the world changes
because of the actions of all of us not
because
of complacency not because of hoping
that change will happen um you have to
be agent of your change especially in
your community when
um when many people are not
um caring about others caring about
our children our future of our children
and i think that's i think that empathy
is really important and empathy and
knowing that you yourself can
when you put your mind to it
make great changes through your advocacy
and i think that's what everyday people
can do the most of all and i just want
to say thank you so much because i
really appreciate you taking the time
out of your day to come on the show is
there anything that you'd like to
promote i don't have a youtube channel i
don't have a blog i don't have uh
i i don't have i have no merch store i
you know i world health network is a is
something that i co-founded with many
other scientists and advocates
feel free to join us everything on our
website is free access
um
uh it's a world health network
and um
yeah everyone please
please stay vigilant that's
and please listen to science the good
science
not the random websites that you might
find that someone might send you
and just be vigilant and i think sharing
with
people in your community and being
self-informed and be because not
everyone will is well informed but be
that person who's informed enough to
uh educate others around you with good
science and evidence
um i think that's the best thing you can
help do
and i i pray everyone gets through this
pandemic
we're all in this together and i pray
everyone has
i want to promote empathy more than
anything
um because this is not a selfish disease
the pandemic it doesn't care about
political affiliations or your personal
beliefs it will do the virus will do
what it does naturally and i think only
by
doing it together
uh working together can we get through
it so thank you so much and stay safe
everyone welcome back everyone i hope
you enjoyed that interview i had with dr
eric feiglding i just want to give a big
thanks to him again for taking the time
just to discuss everything related to
covet i hope you guys learned something
and how important covett still is and
it's still a thing that's happening
right now um you know i
had the opportunity to interview him
while tony was at the dentist not doing
his job here with me on the show oh look
who's there look who's back yeah yeah
i'm here i'm here i'm not at the dentist
this time uh
thanks no really what a great interview
um and i think i think we should let you
do all the interviews from now on and i
can just i
yeah tony will just go to the dentist
again yeah again
i'll just do the interview no no what
what what a great interview i hope
everyone did learn something from that
um even if you pick a few things out of
that interview it'd be great because
covet isn't over but also you can't get
complacent with any kind of anything
with your health you should really uh be
not be complacent so i think that's
that's important to not just you but our
country and our economy it's important
and because we learned a lot of lessons
through the pandemic of what to do and
what to not take uh for granted so i
appreciate you doing that that interview
with dr eric i do want to wish everyone
a happy 4th of july make sure to go
follow us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
you know this is a recorded
live version
um so
don't forget to subscribe to the tony
michaels podcast on youtube in case
there are more recorded videos
smash it also download every single
episode
on apple spotify google and your
favorite directories everywhere do not
forget
to download every single one
gabe we will be back tomorrow at our
normal time noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and simone casting from the mind
touch facebook page just as we do every
single week
until tomorrow
happy fourth of july and surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking